c'est pas si courant l'assemblée
nationale pour une fois unanime cet
après midi au moment de l'hommage rendu
à jacques chaban delmas 81 ans gravement
malade ces dernières années et qui
fêtait aujourd'hui ses cinquante années
de vie politique des députés l'ont élu
président d'honneur de l'assemblée
nationale roland sicard michel levasseur
ses fonctions jacques chaban-delmas
n'était pas venu dans l'hémicycle depuis
longtemps ce n'est pas qu'il boudait
c'est qu'il était fatigué aujourd'hui il
est venu et il n'a pas été déçu lors de
l'échappée legs de conférer à jacques
chaban delmas
une distinction en le proclamant
président d'honneur de l'assemblée
nationale en principe jacques
chaban-delmas n'avait pas prévu de
parler mais il a changé d'avis émotion
j'emporterai comme le plus grand et le
plus précieux des trésors précisément
cette communion d'esprit et de coeur cet
idéal pouvait sauna mais en deux mots la
france et la république c'est que chabon
au palais bourbon c'est une histoire
ancienne
une histoire qui commence en noir et
blanc cinquante ans de présence 16 ans à
la présidence est aujourd'hui surtout
les bons souvenirs
intel 2
personnage il est bien dommage
le schéma delmas a été un grand
parlementaire donc au delà des
divergences politiques chirac est normal
de lui rendre hommage
c'est un homme qui a pesé de tout son
poids dans la vie politique française
c'est un grand homme et je suis très
heureux et honoré de l'avoir dans ma
famille politique mais de le fêter ici
et puis il ya les observateurs ce qu'ils
ont vu chaban à l'oeuvre et qui se
rappelle les meilleurs moments quand il
est arrivé ici la belle auréole d'un
général 20h20 l'existence et la donne
est une sorte de coup de jeune chaque
mission
jacques chaban delmas qui est en tout
cas décidé de laisser la place aux
jeunes
chamand raccroche en 98 pour la première
fois depuis 50 ans il ne sera pas
candidat